les monstres effraie les monstres
fascine il ne laisse personne
indifférent un mois après halloween la
médiathèque de maurepas vous invite à
découvrir les créatures fantastiques qui
ont marqué la littérature
je suis assez fan de tout ce qui est
littérature fantastique de science
fiction fantasy etc et je me suis
toujours rendu compte que les monstres
sont partout dans la littérature que ça
fait vraiment partie de quasiment de
l'inconscient collectif mais que quand
on parle de monstres on parle aux
enfants
et pourtant les monstres existe aussi
pour les adultes romans policiers
science fiction séries télévisées ou
encore blockbusters américains limitent
en bête envahissent nos livres et nos
écrans l'exemple parfait ensemencé
twilight qui fait un carton au cinéma
qui vient d'un d'un livre mais et qui
vient d'un bouquin de la fin du 19e
siècle
dracula de bram stocker je voulais
montrer aux adultes pour public adulte
que ce ne sont absolument pas des sous
littérature est qu'aujourd'hui les
monstres sont effectivement partout au
fil de l'exposition le visiteur découvre
les grandes figures monstrueuses des
oeuvres de référence comme la bible on
passe évidemment par l'antiquité
ensuite les croyances moyenâgeuse autour
du loup garou autour de ces grandes
figures monstrueuses le loup garou le
vampire etc
prenez les super héros américains hulk
par exemple est une adaptation de dr
jekyll et mr hyde un regard intéressant
qui suscite un questionnement sur les
créatures contemporaine comment les
sociétés crée aussi les monstres comment
hier un écho effectivement par rapport à
des peurs collectives des choses comme
ça donc c'est vrai qu'on se poser le
problème du monstre aujourd'hui c'est
quoi notre monstre
les enfants ne seront pas en reste
puisqu'une exposition parallèle leur
présente les portraits des personnages
fantastiques
incontournables les monstrueuses
littérature accueille les visiteurs
jusqu'au 30 novembre
mais des lectures seront organisées
jusqu'en décembre le programme complet
est à retrouver sur internet